[Music]
Snowdonia in Northwest Wales is famed
for its picturesque villages mountains
and valleys beneath the surface however
things are far from tranquil the new
attraction in this former slate mine is
called bounce below before visitors can
try it out they have to Don safety gear
including overalls and a helmet they're
all wondering what awaits them yeah
people denying dark I guess yeah
luckily I'm not claustrophobic I'm
really looking forward to seeing the
layout of pollux I mean the novel ending
told what what it looks like you know
but there's like three levels of nets
and with there with tubes going from one
level to other so same fantastic can't
wait to see it
now there's no turning back after a
short ride on an old mining train they
arrive at the cavern and the underground
trampoline
[Music]
there are three trampolines on different
levels joined by a long tunnel slide
it's all contained in this cavern which
is 60 meters long and 35 meters high
that's twice the size of st. Paul's
Cathedral in London the operators owner
describes the idea behind it it's lots
of different people who are involved
with the company Friends of the company
came up with a concept we want that we
want something unique which we are fake
I feel we have it so it's a world first
also we want we wanted something all
year round all weather and this is the
same temperature all the around it's
just eight degrees Celsius but everyone
is soon warmed up for about 30 euros
they have one hour to jump bump and
bounce to their heart's content so big
it's like my trampoline they're just so
much bigger it's just one so everybody
needs to come here and experience this
it's fantastic I'm exhausted but it's
just a fabulous experience everybody
needs to come and do this this is what
the slate cabin looked like a century
ago back then northern Wales had about
17,000 miners industrialization and the
rise of new materials eventually spelled
the end of the mine
it took six months to create the
underground playground 300 tons of
rubble had to be carted away and a
subterranean Lake also had to be filled
Nick Moriarty is in charge of safety
these are very safe we
accommodates about 100 people at anytime
each anchor has been tested for 5 tons
[Music]
it's not the only adventure offered by
zip world a year ago the company opened
the world's longest zip line just a few
kilometers away the zip line extends 750
meters and visitors fly over the local
landscape at speeds of up to 100
kilometres an hour the company is
already planning another new attraction
project which first person going to tell
about
it's called zips below it's going to be
our zip lines next door and this is
going to be a continuous zip lines where
you're on your wire but we're going to
use computer animation where you'll slip
through fire waterfalls Burt Sean Taylor
and his team hope to draw more and more
tourists to this part of Wales the
underground trampoline is doing its part
high flying thrills for fun seekers of
all ages